und jetzt das heute journal
[Musik]
30.000 wünsche auf die fäden eines
fliegenden teppichs beschrieben
das optische wunder der berliner feiern
dieses jahr vielleicht ein zarter
hinweis dass vor 30 jahren ein großer
wunsch von millionen in erfüllung die
aber noch unzählbar viele unerfüllt in
der luft liegt
guten abend wir sind das glücklichste
volk der erde hat walter momper berlins
regierender das verkündet er konnte ins
bett gehen als er nach den ersten
stunden sicher sein durfte
es bleibt alles friedlich diese nacht
unsere reporterinnen henriette de
maizière und stefanie dosch die den
feiertag für uns in berlin erlebten
berichten von einer ich gerade
übermütigen feier aber von einer sehr
positiven stimmung
die organisatoren des programms die
offiziellen redner und die bürger die
kamen haben alle gespür dafür gezeigt
wie vielschichtig dieses datum und seine
deutsche vor und nachgeschichte sind
[Musik]
brandenburger tor zwei bühnen eine
weltkugel mit bildern die um die welt
gingen
[Musik]
momente des freudentaumels vor 30 jahren
die lehre aus der geschichte so der
bundespräsident mauern lassen sich ein
reißen auch die heutigen wenn wir heute
abend mit dankbarkeit sogar mit tränen
in den augen an die mutigen von damals
erinnern dann können wir doch nicht
gleichzeitig dabei zugucken wie das was
sie erkämpft haben in vergessenheit
gerät aber quer durch unser land sind
neue mauern entstanden mauern aus frust
mauern aus wut und hass die neuen mauern
in unserem land die haben wir selbst
gebaut und nur wir selber können sie
einreißen
trotz nasskaltem novemberwetter kamen
zehntausende über ihnen der teppich
gespannt mit 30.000 zetteln wünsche für
ein friedliches zusammenleben
wir müssen jeden tag darum kämpft dass
es erhalten bleibt diese freiheit das
ist das wichtigste für uns dass wir
diese freiheit die wir unter 30 jahren
nicht hätten vorstellen können und diese
zeit dass wir uns die erhalten
ich wünsche mir dass wir noch weiter
zusammenwachsen dass diese diskrepanzen
zwischen ost und west doch endlich mal
verschmelzen
ja ich wünsche mir auf jeden fall dass
es wirklich bleibt und ja das war so
weiterleben über das bisher gemacht
haben ich komme mal stolz auf das sein
was bis jetzt passiert ist
kerzen bereits am morgen von der
bundeskanzlerin politikern und bürgern
an der mauer gedenkstätte für die opfer
des sed regimes in der kapelle der
versöhnung erinnerte angela merkel dann
auch an den 9 november 1938 als jüdische
geschäfte und synagogen brannten erneut
im november in dem sich in besonderer
weise sowohl die fürchterlichen als auch
die glücklichen momente unserer
geschichte widerspiegeln ermahnt uns
dass wir hass rassismus und
antisemitismus entschlossen
entgegentreten müssen
auf der bühne setzten am abend sänger
zeit zeugen und die berliner
staatskapelle ein gemeinsames zeichen
für frieden keine jubelstimmung mir
einen innehalten und die aufforderung
den geist von 89 weiterzutragen
erinnerung ist nicht asche sondern glut
wenn wir dafür sorgen dass niemand durch
gewalt geängstigt wird wenn sie unserer
freiheit wertschätzen und verteidigen
dann können wir uns alle 89er nennen
berlin erlebte heute ein nachdenkliches
aber auch berühren das fest mit einem
großen feuerwerk für die friedliche
revolution der ostdeutschen
[Musik]
30 jahre später braucht es schon bilder
und emotionen von damals um große
emotionen wieder neu zu wecken aber dann
funktioniert es also mit details waren
also privatreisen nach dem ausland
können ohne vorliegen von
voraussetzungen reiseanlässe und
verwandtschaftsverhältnisse beantragt
werden kurzfristig erteilt
das tritt nach meiner kenntnis
unverzüglich auf liebe
[Musik]
doch deutlich meine mutter und mein
phasen da drüben kann er über ihre
männer hätten besuchen gehen ja
[Musik]
das ist endlich unsere stimme die stelle
der freiheit vor einem jahr gegen bochum
weiter die phasen
[Applaus]
also nicht validen straße über die
grenze da aufgemacht sind die vom osten
rüber die vom westen auch und das ist
nur da durchs brandenburger tor gelang
es für das ganze überhaupt nicht mehr
kontrollieren nachströmen apa gegen lord
nichts wir gehen rüber die anderen busse
und alle umarmen sich in der mitte das
ist geschichte läuft wiedervereinigung
wollen wollen die meisten nicht nur
richtig haben wenn ich der meinung
[Applaus]
und noch immer sind bilder dabei die man
noch nicht hundertmal gesehen hat zdf de
ist die adresse zu einer schatzkiste de
die zdf mediathek ist voller material
videos dokumentation hintergründe zu 30
jahre mal auffallen
auch die nachrichtensendung von damals
da können sie noch mal erleben wie
redaktionen reagierten auf dieses leid
leider seltene ereignis eine breaking
news über die man sich stundenlang
freuen kann
die nachrichten dieses tages von heinz
wolf zu diesem besonderen datum hat auch
der vorsitzende des zentralrats der
juden in deutschland josef schuster auf
die so unterschiedlichen historischen
ereignisse an einem neunter november in
deutschland hingewiesen
er könne natürlich nachvollziehen dass
der dreißigsten jahrestag des mauerfalls
einen besonderen stellenwert einnehme
deshalb dürfe man aber auch nicht die
geschehnisse des 9
november 1938 vergessen sagte schuster
der nordwest-zeitung nazi-schergen
hatten damals synagogen jüdische
geschäfte und wohnungen in brand
gesteckt und jüdische mitbürger ermordet
die iranische führung entfernt sich
weiter von den vereinbarungen des
internationalen atom abkommens wie vor
einigen tagen angekündigt ließ sie in
der atomanlage fordo die anreicherung
von uran wieder aufnehmen der iran
begründet seinen schrittweisen rückzug
aus dem vertrag damit dass der westen
seine zusagen für mehr wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit nicht einhalte
insbesondere nachdem die usa aus dem
vertrag ausgestiegen sind und sanktionen
gegen iran verhängt haben
brasiliens ex-präsident lula da silva
hat sich direkt nach seiner freilassung
gleich einen heftigen schlagabtausch mit
staatschef boson euro geliefert
sie nannten sich gegenseitig schurken
und lügner lula wurde gestern
überraschend aus der haft entlassen
er profitiert von einem urteil des
obersten bundesgerichts nach dem
straftäter erst nach ausschöpfung aller
rechtsmittel ins gefängnis müssen
der 74 jährige war wegen korruption und
geldwäsche zu mehr als acht jahren haft
verurteilt worden
er kann das urteil noch einmal anfechten
von allen regionen dieser erde ist
australien die für uns fernste wir
verbinden mit dem fünften kontinent
bilder großer natur endlose landschaften
und geschichten von menschen die sich
als enkel und urenkel von pionieren
verstehen und sich durch nichts
erschüttern lassen was australiens natur
eben in der provinz new south wales
jetzt ab verlangt muss auch sie
überfordern
wir berichten immer wieder über große
waldbrände mittlerweile ja auch bei uns
regelmäßig aus kalifornien aber bilder
wie die aktuellen von down under haben
wir noch nicht gesehen
eine fahrt in die hölle da draußen
temperaturen von einigen hundert grad wo
die brände wüten alles vernichten
feuerwehrleute die da rein müssen und
nur hoffen können heil wieder raus zu
kommen
ein einsatz wie sie ihn noch nicht
erlebt haben nie gab es im bundesstaat
new south wales so viele brände
zeitgleich katastrophal
außer kontrolle es gibt verletzte es
gibt tote und die zahlen werden wohl
noch steigen aus sydney eine knappe
flugstunde nur entfernt stimmt der
premierminister darauf ein
wir müssen leider mit weiteren schlimmen
nachrichten rechnen
die zerstörung ist gewaltig und einige
gebiete sind komplett abgeschnitten wie
konnten sie noch nicht erreichen
wir müssen uns darauf einstellen dass es
von dort furchtbare meldungen geben über
radio und fernsehen werden die menschen
zur flucht aufgerufen viele lassen also
alles zurück und viele verlieren dann
auch alles mindestens 150 häuser sind
verbrannt
rasend schnell haben sich die feuer
ausgebreitet immer weiter ins land
gefressen
das feuer kam gestern schon ganz nah an
unser haus über nacht sah es dann so aus
als ging es zurück aber jetzt hat der
wind wieder gedreht
und irgendwie ist alles außer kontrolle
kontrolle darum bemühen sich die
einsatzkräfte ohne pause und mit allen
mitteln
aufgeben ist keine option aber
weiterkämpfen extrem gefährlich
ich zittere am ganzen körper meine
stimme versagt das war verdammt knapp er
mit dem helikopter
aber ehrlich ohne die hätten das nie
gepackt es geht um existenzen es geht um
leben und tod retten was zu retten ist
und die verzweiflung nicht gewinnen
lassen wo die feuerwalze durch ist steht
nicht mehr viel es braucht oft nur
minuten um alles in schutt und asche zu
legen
die flammen waren einfach überall so
hoch das war ein inferno die apokalypse
die hölle auf erden hitze wind und
weiter kein regen der wetterbericht hat
nichts zu bieten was hoffnung macht
monate lang teils jahrelang hat diese
ecke des landes keinen tropfen regen
abbekommen
die rekord dürre hat den boden bereitet
für diese katastrophe wälder und büsche
brennen wie zunder
und jetzt fragt man sich nach so einem
bericht aber es gibt kein konzept für
jetzt die natur hat übernommen
die menschen können ihr nichts
entgegenstellen das bleibt nur flucht
und beten und für uns weiter berichten
auch der andere teil dieses nachrichten
tages sport beginnt nachdenklich im
deutschen fußball wird an diesem
wochenende an den torhüter robert enke
erinnert er hatte sich schwer an
depressionen erkrankt vor zehn jahren
das leben genommen
simone friedrich berichtet mit der die
denken die nuthe wollen wir oben
erinnern und zu einem natürlichen umgang
mit depression auch hoch der deutsche
fussball gut für eine minute hier vor
dem spiel bayern gegen dortmund erinnern
an den torwart robert enke und einen
aufmerksam machen auf die volkskrankheit
depression und auf die hilfsangebote
auch vor der partie paderborn augsburg
auch stehen innehalten ein zeichen
setzen
eine aktion des dfb und der robert enke
stiftung mit der vorsitzenden der witwe
des torhüters teresa enke setzt sich
seit 2009 für die öffentliche aufklärung
über depressionen ein
ich möchte den menschen eben vermitteln
dass es eine krankheit ist dass es
halber ist dass es nichts mit schwäche
zu tun hat morgen ist es zehn jahre her
dass robert enke sich das leben genommen
hat im alter von 32 jahren
bei den para weltmeisterschaften in
dubai gibt es für die deutschen
behinderten leichtathleten die erste
medaille gold über 200 meter kam er im
grab von susann mit knappem vorsprung
ins ziel und damit also gold für die 28
jährige aus leverkusen und jetzt die
lottozahlen dieses samstags sie lauten
wie immer ohne gewähr
9 28 31 33 40 44 superzahl 7 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 5 56
noch die wetteraussichten morgen scheint
nach nebelauflösung auf die sonne nur an
der nordsee kann es einzelne schauer
geben
weil vier bis zehn grad in den nächsten
tagen wird es kühler und vor allem am
mittwoch fällt im südosten schnee bis in
die tieferen lagen dabei kann es glatt
werden
morgen sonntag wird die koalition
endlich eine kuh vom eis ziehen und die
heißt grundrente mal schauen was draus
wird
und wenn sie ein ergebnis gibt was taugt
morgen ab bis dahin einen schönen sollte
[Musik]